let's assemble the council of geeks and
let's find something else to pick apart
so this time I want to talk about some
comic books that should be made into
movies but probably never will be I'm
gonna stick specifically to non
superhero comic books i'm not talking
about who should play any of these parts
i just want to stick to story I want to
talk conceptual level on this so I'm
going to start with the biggest name and
the one that most people are going to
recognize we're going to start with the
Sandman it looked for a little while
like we've got to have a back door into
this because gaming himself was supposed
to direct an adaptation of death the
high cost of living which is a spin off
from the Sandman there's been no word on
that though for years at this point I'm
not holding my breath on it ever
happening had it happened and been
successful we could have gotten this now
I'm not so sure there's a lot of tricky
things and trying to adapt this if you
haven't read it in short this thing is
sprawling it is massive but it's not a
singular narrative it's not an epic
about one character a lot of these
stories the the main the guy in the
title Sandman Morpheus the Lord Of
Dreams barely factors it at all but they
take place within his realm of dreams he
comes in at the end he's not the focus
of a lot of things which taking the
comic books in the grand scope of
everything is part of what makes it
brilliant you can't do that in a film
now there was an argument that you could
do it as a compilation style TV show
stick it on HBO I would very gladly
watch that but you could do it as a film
I do honestly believe that and you could
do it pretty much wrap the whole thing
up in three films but let's start with
the first one because one thing that you
should never do and they and they
finally stopped trying to do after so
many non-starter franchise movies you
need to stop making movies thinking
we're going to get to make a sequel set
things up so there's stuff to pick up
but don't don't leave the story
deliberately halfway finished you know
learn from the golden compass for God's
sake you gotta do the first one you
gotta do preludes and nocturnes you can
do it pretty much straight and actually
that's your key
to this whole thing and that was Game
ins key in to getting this thing
accepted is that it's the closest to a
traditional superhero story he's
stripped of his powers he has to gain
all of his powerful objects and reclaim
his his realm of dreams and that story
in that journey is one that lends itself
to film it should translate pretty
cleanly really the only thing I changes
I'd swap out dark destiny for the
Corinthian and call it a day even if you
don't get to do the rest that's a fully
satisfying story if you get to do more
second one should be done should be
seasons of Miss and then you wrap it up
with kindly ones those one specifically
should be the second and third
installments because they are well
they're one the major stories that focus
specifically on Morpheus and also have
antagonistic characters there are other
stories that focus on him like his
journey to try and find his brother
destruction but there's there's no bad
guy in that and I'm sorry as much as it
works in the comic book if you're making
a movie for the masses they need a bad
guy and seasons of Miss has that the
kindly ones have that and you could very
easily set everything up so that it all
pans out across the three I do think
it's doable it's just a question of
whether or not Warner Brothers ever gets
the balls to do it we'll get something
we'll get this in some form eventually
just because it's too big a name just
like eventually we were going to get
watchman unfortunately we got watchman
but you know it's gonna happen sooner or
later I just hope that they do it right